[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein tolles herzhaftes
gericht und dieses könnt ihr sogar
wirklich ganz ganz toll mitnehmen wir
machen nämlich kleine teigtaschen
gefüllt mit einer chili nicht chilli
philippi stage ist natürlich auch kommt
ich glaube ich mache filme chili steak
füllung und zwar finde ich darf die idee
gekommen weil der murat weiße pulver und
da gibt es diese philly philips take
that which is genau eigentlich ist ein
schwieriges wort
und da habe ich gedacht kommt diese
füllung nehmen wir jetzt machen wir
teigtaschen daraus keine sandwiches aber
ihr könnt natürlich auch sein was draus
machen und meine subway sandwiches mal
ausprobieren und ich mache jetzt zuerst
mal einen hefeteig der wird dann später
ausgerollt und da kommt dann die leckere
füllung rein und murat darf dann zum
probieren kommen als auch für den
hefeteig verwende ich 500 gramm mehl
einen esslöffel warmes wasser einen
esslöffel zucker einen halben würfel
hefe ein teelöffel salz 40 milliliter
sonnenblumenöl und 250 milliliter
lauwarmer milch ganz klasse starten wir
jetzt mit dem hefeteig mit der hefe wird
zerbröselt in eine rührschüssel ein
bisschen wasser rein und zucker und ihr
könnt den hefe zeigen natürlich auch
ganz einfach mit den händen verkneten
ich mache jetzt nur mit der kitchenette
weil es einfach etwas schneller und
einfacher geht
hefe zucker wasser vermischen
[Musik]
hier kommen jetzt einfach die übrigen
zutaten rein also mehl milch salz und öl
und dann einfach den hefeteig in fünf
bis sieben minuten richtig schön
geschmeidig kneten datei gesetzt fertig
das ist auch ein bisschen fester hier
verteilt aber er klebt nicht mehr das
ist ganz wichtig es soll jetzt einfach
hier zu einer kugel zusammen rolle
[Musik]
dann die schüssel mit back trance betten
und ein bisschen back trends bei
obendrauf damit der teig nicht
austrocknet abdecken und eine stunde
ruhen lassen und so etwa in einer halben
stunde bereit ist dann schon mal die
füllung vor für die füllung verwende ich
500 gramm rumpsteak das schneide ich
gleich in streifen eine knoblauchzehe
eine zwiebel eine grüne paprika eine
chilischote 70 gramm getrocknete tomaten
und die sind in öl eingelegt ich
verwende etwas tun um käse für den
besseren geschmack oregano champignons
und käse die zwiebel und knoblauch ich
schneide ich jetzt in feine würfel
gestellt haben jetzt schon
[Musik]
und dann könnt ihr einfach das ganze
klein geschnittene gemüse alles in eine
schüssel geben
und die chili schote die schneide ich
jetzt in eine rille
ich kämpfe gerade gegen die zügel an und
ich glaube ich schaffe den kampf aber
ich weiß es noch nicht
dann die paprika und da scheint sich
immer unten den boden ab und dann an den
vier seiten hier einfach die scheiben
runter dann einfach in feine streifen
[Musik]
die champignons habe ich jetzt einfach
nur geputzt mit einem trockenen
küchentuch die darf man nämlich nicht
waschen weil sie sich ansonsten richtig
voll saugen und ich habe jetzt hier auch
ganz kleine champignons und die schneide
ich einfach einschreiben
das macht ihr entweder so oder einfach
so
[Musik]
und jetzt zum schluss noch das steak in
streifen schneiden nicht zu kleiden aber
auch nicht zu groß
nämlich ein bisschen öl da habe ich
jetzt das öl von den getrockneten
tomaten einfach aufgehoben
es hat immer einen supertollen und
intensivem geschmack dann erhalten und
jetzt die stack streifen ganz scharf
anbraten und deswegen stehe ich jetzt
auch nicht alle auf einmal sein damit
die pfannen schönheitsbad immer nur ein
paar schöne antraten und dann gleich
wieder rausnehmen
[Musik]
dann das restliche öl nehmen und dann
das ganze gemüse rein den herd haben
jetzt ein bisschen runter gestellt auch
mittel hohen hitze und an das gemüse so
lange an warten bis die flüssigkeit fast
komplett weg
[Musik]
so sieht das gemüse jetzt auf gewürzt
habe ich das ja noch gar nicht jetzt
erst mal ein bisschen salz und pfeffer
aber ganz vorsichtig denn ich nehme
gleich zum käse und der turm käse der
ist wirklich sehr aromatisch sei
intensiv im geschmack also jetzt nicht
zu sehr unterstützt einfach diesen
geschmack dann hat er mich dann mit dem
salz erstmal vorsichtig oregano recht
gemüse nehme ich jetzt hier vom
herunterzählen danach kurz das fleisch
ein bisschen tanzen und werfen soll
jetzt kann ich die hersteller platz
stehen lassen die füllung kann auch ein
bisschen abkühlen nehme ich meine track
der richtig gut aufgegangen ist und den
teile ich jetzt in acht portionen 1
einfach mit kugel machen vierteln und
dann als ein achtel viertel und dann
nochmal halbieren
dann jedes zu einer kugel formen
[Musik]
und jetzt rollig detail kugeln einfach
schön aus zu einem großen kreis
so etwa 25 cm im durchmesser
[Musik]
woher weiß ich dass das 25 sind ganz
ablegen dann einfach kurz zur seite
legen und die anderen auch noch
ausrollen nämlich eine teig platte und
diebe streiche ich mit etwas flüssiger
butter dann kommt da eine scheibe käse
drauf da nehme ich jetzt den kv
schnittkäse weil er einfach die tolle
schmelz eigenschaft hat darüber das
gemüse dann etwas tun um käse und der
wirt aus kuhmilch gemacht und hat
einfach einen schönen intensiven
geschmack weil er im fass gereift wird
darüber kommen dann die stack streifen
weil die steak streifen und das gemüse
ist so schon ein richtig leckeres
pastagericht könnt ihr natürlich auch
machen und darüber dann noch mal eine
scheibe kascha damit einfach so schön
darüber schnitzt und jetzt hier den teig
nehmen und so ein bisschen entfalten
legen
und wieso einen kleinen sack
zusammenfalten
[Musik]
so sehen sie jetzt aus und jetzt nehme
ich hier noch 1 1
da kommt bisschen wasser rein dann etwas
für gut und da kann ich es hier
verrühren und das gepäck einfach damit
bestreichen
[Musik]
und dann ab in den backofen und dann
kommen die jungs gleich zum probieren
denn das gepäck sollte man am besten
ganz heiß noch essen
[Musik]
so jetzt sind die teigtaschen fertig und
die jungs dürfen probieren
ich habe hier drei dennoch hat und
können sie nicht alleine ja und zwar mit
macht npd und praktikant das ist unser
praktikant de ist unser praktikant ist
das glück irgendwie mache ich gleich
gemerkt gerade wenn sie zwei anschaut
das ist derselbe dna strang ja nur aber
nur einer von beiden hatten
schulabschluss ist zu raten wer aber wie
bei jungs probiert es nur aus ich weiß
welch gabel messer geben
die spitzel groß die kameras ohnehin
schon dünne oder ja muss aufpassen und
nicht nämlich viele das auf ihr gelungen
da ich wahrscheinlich den etwas drin
machst du noch nie probiert hast da ist
ein cooler tool um käse drin ist es
normal käse er richtig würzig richtig
ging probiert aber ich muss dazu sagen
viele meiner türkischen freunde kennen
tut und käse aus der türkei und dem ce
das probiere ich nicht aber der käse ist
nicht zu vergleichen mit dem aus der
türkei mein papa hatte er mitgebracht
und der wird halt früher immer in so
echtes leder holz und nehme ich es
realistisch früher in der käse wurde in
eine ziege verpackt ja also der vorteil
da wird alles tiere geschlachtet früher
hat man den käse in dieser zeit
sozusagen noch sich den medien
der hat so stark geschmeckt aber der
hier ist nicht so dass im fass gereift
wenn die kamera aus ist werde ich
zweimal aua machen aber wichtig
als ich jetzt mit gabel messer legen wo
es nicht um sex streifen und die habe
ich noch ganz kurz vorher angebraten
schülerin mit jeder pcs was mich auch
lokal oder sichern sich auch und hummer
natürlich wird es jetzt im ding geben im
food truck ist das nicht geil die
geschichte zweier autos doch sagt du
hast so ein chili cheese subway baguette
gegessen und dann habe ich gedacht ich
[Musik]
mach das bitte nicht das bekommen wir
drei männer dazu dass einfach stehen am
morgen sind glücklich zu machen
mit getrockneten tomaten das rezept gibt
es zum nachlesen auf sell ist wie das
blog de ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und ist zweimal juni
ich sehe doppelt und liegt jetzt ein
gebackener papa jetzt warum das grün ist
undicht geworden ist
das ist nur die erste mal gefüttert
[Applaus]
[Musik]